let's go uh why don't we go next oh
there's just so many people who are
interested in uh
in in getting on today why don't we go
to
sean from college station
yes i can my apologies i had my keyboard
on the floor
oh my how does the keyboard even get on
the floor uh
i have a small son and he loves to uh
play with my keyboard oh gotcha all
right well what's going on
uh not too much um so i had a quick
question
um i've asked it a couple times before
but i know you get tons of questions
um how would you feel about
trying a medicare for all in the same
way that they're doing the
electoral vote compact so for example
as we know the states uh
are signing up and once we get to a
certain number of states or certain
number of electoral votes
that's when the the law will kick in uh
i hear a lot of people complain
with medicare for all on the state level
that oh well then a bunch of people are
just going to move to that state and
you're going to have
you know it's going to be so overloaded
in that state that there's no way
any one state could handle it so what if
what would you feel about like maybe
some sort of interstate vote
or interstate compact where okay once we
have a certain number of the population
you know so there's a couple different
there's a couple different
issues there okay the first one is
because you know the national population
national popular
uh vote interstate compact is not really
analogous to what you're suggesting with
medicare for all
because it it it's just a completely
different thing
there's no way that if enough states do
medicare for all you all of a sudden
have
federal medicare for all i think the
idea of
starting medicare for all within one
state is a great idea vermont
tried to do it a few years ago and they
ultimately were not able to
um the the question of people moving to
that state
it'll become a problem more because of
the supply of medical services
financially it shouldn't be a problem
because if people move to that state
they'll be paying taxes to the state
which will support the program okay so
that that's
the concern is less about people moving
from a financial standpoint it's that
it'll create demand for way more doctors
and presumably some doctors will move
there as well so let's keep thinking
about that i'm going to let you go
because it really sounds like you have
your hands very very full there with
your son
very much appreciate the call let's take
a quick break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we're going right back to the phones
momentarily
a lot of the shirts you see me wearing
on youtube are actually made by a
company called
teddy stratford i love these shirts and
that's why i asked them to be a sponsor
of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button-up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because
all of their shirts come with a patented
zipper
hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but most
importantly just overall it makes the
shirt fit
much better and look better the
carefully designed shirt is also
cut in a way that improves the look of
your upper body physique it has a really
nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed
collar that won't fall down and lay flat
which i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout